you
I'm optimistic and I think for those of
us who are engaged in the world I feel
that people are good within in fact we
have many similarities one of the things
that I have found in my work is that
whenever I had a chance to sit down and
have a cup of coffee with someone albeit
in the former Soviet Union or in
Afghanistan I find that we have so much
in common we have the same hopes and
dreams for each other's kids we want
food on the table we want them educated
we want a house over their heads and and
the similarities are there it's not the
differences it's the similarities and I
remember one of my colleagues said to me
when I was working in Russia so if only
we had more conversations like this
during the Cold War maybe we wouldn't
have had and I love comments like that I
think it's very true
right now I am waiting for this age to
pass somewhat because of the current
administration that we have and I feel
that from an international standpoint we
are a little bit at a standstill the
plans have already been made for the
upcoming coming years there has not been
a change in the international foreign
policy and the way that we engage
countries are the way that we put money
into education and so to me it requires
us to have a change in the president but
what it also means is that I believe
that the winds of change are actually
occurring right now I Reverend Jim
Wallace once gave a wonderful analogy he
raised his finger and he looked it and
he said what happens in Washington DC is
that the Senators they always look to
see which direction the wind is blowing
well we can continue to elect people
they're always going to test the wind
what we need to do as individuals is
change the direction of the wind so my
my hope right now in my optimism is that
that wind is changing and I think that
people from around the world are now
understanding that we are part of this
bigger world and you see this momentum
especially against poverty occurring all
over the place thanks to the help of
bono the Gates Foundation and folks like
that
you